let's cross live to Nairobi and speak to
skies chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
and Stuart first of all I understand
you've heard a couple of explosions
there what can you tell us about that
yeah the very big one actually a few
minutes ago and one within the last
half-hour now we've got to assume that
this is part of the moves through the
complex we know yesterday that they were
actually this to the military with
blowing holes and some walls to get
through however we now know that the
forensic teams are inside and if some
dove it odd that that they would be
doing this but of course it is a large
complex and they could be a bit a
completely different part of it
however we do know that the bomb squad
who have been in there bomb disposal
squad say that they came across three
booby-trapped bombs today and came
across ten live grenades and we were
under the impression that they had
withdrawn now saying that it was secure
so it's possible of course that there's
been an accident it was a pretty big
blast however we haven't seen any
ambulances so let's sort of assume that
actually it is just part of either their
clearance operation or a controlled
explosion or some type of efforts to get
through a wall or plants blow their way
through an alley that or a part of the
building that's collapse because as
we've seen it is a real mess inside
three floors down the Spotty's in there
who the forensics want to get to and to
say this is a massive crime scene now so
the forensics officers from all over the
world are in there trying to piece
together what's going on british are
there as well
interested the Americans and I'm told by
an intelligent source that the Americans
are also concerned about the fact that
there was such an attack on a shopping
mall and of course America as well
happily loads them in there's virtually
no security in those and they're wanting
to actually find out more about how this
was done in case it could happen in the
United States
if there was a rental of a shop for
example and it was filled with weapons
with never very little oversight from
the management of the complex that's all
being looked at but is something
obviously the Americans are considering
as well and Stuart while you were
talking there about those explosions we
can actually see smoke rising from the
building